I used to hate my grandfather when I was
a child
as he constantly tried to teach me
boring lessons about how to live life
distracting me from Carefree games
the world is tough for young people
today he constantly repeated seeking to
simplify other people's lives with his
advice
unfortunately only after his death and
decades later facing the realities of a
harsh world did I understand the value
of what he wrote in his diary and why he
wanted to teach me
he was respected by the whole town a
sage man with a tremendous Gray beard
who wanted me to understand these life
lessons as soon as possible
listen carefully son
and remember this
life is like a book
some chapters are sad some are happy
but all are necessary for the full story
learn how to change a flat tire on your
vehicle
if you don't value your time
neither will others
the strongest people are not those who
show strength in front of us
but those who fight battles we know
nothing about
the pain you feel today
will be the strength you feel tomorrow
turn your wounds into wisdom
when writing the story of your life
don't let anyone else hold the pen
don't put off important medical checkups
practice self-compassion
we are all human
and everyone makes mistakes
Time Heals almost everything
give it time
a good laugh and a long sleep are the
two best cures for anything
sometimes you win
sometimes you learn
forgiveness is not for the other person
it's for your peace of mind
sometimes we're tested not to show our
weaknesses
but to discover our strengths
the calmer you are
the clearer you think
learn to cook a few basic dishes it's a
valuable life skill
patience is power
sometimes you have to let go of
something good to make room for
something better
never tolerate disrespect
not even from yourself
listen more than you speak
for wisdom often comes from Silence
create and stick to a personal budget
what other people think of you is none
of your business
kindness is a language that the deaf can
hear and the blind can see
worrying is like a rocking chair
it gives you something to do but gets
you nowhere
you can't start the next chapter of your
life if you keep re-reading the last one
the best view comes after the hardest
climb
courage doesn't always Roar
sometimes it's the quiet voice at the
end of the day saying
I will try again tomorrow
never lose your sense of humor
laughter is the best medicine for the
soul
you'll never find a rainbow if you're
looking down
always pay off your credit card debt
it'll save you trouble later
the best revenge is massive success
the more you give the more you receive
the heart that shares is the heart
that's full
tough times don't last
but tough people do
the most valuable currency is not money
but time
spend it wisely
a ship is safe in Harbor
but that's not what shifts are for
the way you treat others reflects Who
You Are
not who they are
it's not about having what you want but
wanting what you have
don't wait for the perfect moment take
it and make it perfect
believe in yourself and the rest will
fall into place
don't be afraid to take risks and try
new things
life is too short to always play it safe
always take responsibility for your
actions
for it is the mark of a mature
individual
take a deep breath
it's just a bad day not a bad life
don't say someday
say now
for someday may never come
donate to charity
small acts change lives
a person who doesn't make mistakes
doesn't make anything at all
you cannot change the direction of the
wind
but you can adjust your sales to reach
your destination
the only constant in life is change
embrace it and you'll grow
say please and thank you often
you can't change the past but can shape
your future by learning from it
the heaviest burden we carry is the
weight of our expectations
it's better to be alone than in Bad
Company
when you stop chasing the wrong things
the right ones catch up
there are no shortcuts to any place
worth going
you never know how strong you are until
being strong is the only choice you have
do not let what you cannot do into fear
with what you can do
the best way to gain self-confidence is
to do what you are afraid to do
a River cuts through Rock not because of
its power
but because of its persistence
there is no elevator to success
you have to take the stairs
the greatest risk is not taking one
happiness is not something you postpone
for the future
it is something you design for the
present
your life does not get better by chance
it gets better by change
you are confined only by the walls you
build yourself
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure
focus on what you can control
and let go of what you cannot
take time to enjoy life's Simple
Pleasures
it's in these moments that we often find
the most Joy
give without expecting anything in
return
the only time you should ever look back
is to see how far you've come
you cannot have a positive life and a
negative mind
doubt kills more dreams than failure
ever will
in the face of adversity remember that
Diamonds Are Made under pressure
if you get tired
learn to rest not to quit
do not let the shadows of your past
darken the doorstep of your future
do not postpone joy for the sake of the
future the morrow is promised to no one
the first step to getting anywhere is
deciding you're not willing to stay
where you are
stop wasting time on women
don't chase women instead
focus on your growth values in
cultivating kindness
the right person will find their way to
you at the perfect moment
without the need for chasing
never bend your head always hold it high
look the world straight in the eye
the true test of a man's character is
what he does when no one is watching
you don't have to win every argument
agreed to disagree
spend time with the elderly
their wisdom and experiences are
invaluable
one day or day one
you decide
if you want to keep these lessons for
yourself you can buy an ebook through
the link in the description or in the
pin comment